this is Tokyo the capital of Japan
this is its Bay and this is Kenzo
tange's plan for Tokyo a massive
floating Metropolis with a spine that
doubled as a highway connecting the
world's largest city to the world's
largest city built on water
tange's radical plan was just one of
many
multiple plants to transform Tokyo into
a thing the world had never seen before
so why
did Kenzo and the others design these
cities on water why do they look the way
they do and why is this introduction so
dramatic seriously why
it's right after the second world war
and Tokyo is a mess
devastated cities job Seekers and
returning soldiers are pushing many
Japanese towards the capital
the City's population is growing and
Tokyo's Elites are restless desperate
for any answer to the problem of two
little homes but too many people
they consider building satellite cities
but there's a problem people are hard to
predict just because you build new
places there's no guarantee that people
will move to them
they need a different answer
and so one day A man gives it to them
hi Sakura Kano is the chairman of the
Japanese housing corporation instead of
expanding Tokyo further into land He
suggests they create it
the city shouldn't bother with building
new buildings on its boundaries but they
should build them next to its heart
thirteen years before the Americans used
nuclear weapons to destroy two Japanese
cities Kano wanted to do the opposite
instead of annihilation creation He
suggests blowing up a mountain with
atomic bombs that way they could gather
enough land to fill in two-thirds of the
entire Bay
creating a 1 500 square kilometer plot
that they could build upon
this is the first plan for the Tokyo bay
I can tell that you're not using a VPN
you unsave uncivilized animal
that's why you need surf shark the
sponsor of this week's video
surf shark gets your personal data
protected from big companies or cyber
criminals something that young men who
spend way too much time on the internet
watching the most disgusting things
online probably should keep an eye on
surf shark will protect your privacy
even when connected to public Wi-Fi
which can be a gold mine for hackers
also if you're lucky enough to watch
Netflix with someone real a VPN can mess
your IP address
so you can watch whatever show you want
wherever you want
I once needed to perform CPR on my
father but when I opened up YouTube it
told me that the video was not available
in my country luckily I had surf shark
and I could change my location to a
country with a good sense for Public
Safety
you can do the same thing by trying out
surf shark click the link in the
description and use the code hug deal to
get three extra months for free
[Music]
surrounding the bay are four prefectures
the Tokyo City saitama Kanagawa and
sheba
Kano was a descendant of Chiba noblemen
in the future he'd become the
prefectures governor
Chiba never really had the pull of Tokyo
City but by building land between them
Kano could change that
He suggests constructing a new
international airport at futsu
connecting the outside world to a small
chibin fishing Village right next to his
new airport he plans a massive
residential belt crossing the entire Bay
on both sides are forests
on the East a massive industrial Zone
with 24 zones and on the west more
industrial zones which are separated
from the residential belt by two long
strips a forest
the west side is purposely dug 20 meters
deep so that 100 000 ton tankers can
dock
and finally slicing the entire Bay
perpendicularly is a 20 meter deep Canal
connecting haeda with the port of Chiba
kano's plan was profound he opened up
the minds of Tokyo's desperate Elites to
the idea of building on the bay but his
breakthrough plan wasn't perfect filling
in two-thirds of the bay with land is
not cheap even if you do blow up a
mountain so instead his plan gets picked
up by the head of the council for
industrial planning Matsunaga
this is the neo-tokyo plan
instead of massive chunks of land the
bay is now filled with Islands
more detailed than kano's first plan the
Neo Tokyo plan has eight distinct zones
commercial industrial residential
Recreation and two airports instead of
one
the last three zones specifically
describe ground transportation the
largest being a super Expressway that
surrounds the entire Bay and also
crosses it the smallest one being a
smaller Expressway encircling the bay
Within
and the last being a super rapid Railway
that hugs the super Expressway and
connects the new islands with
prefectures outside of the Tokyo
metropolitan area
in the Neo Tokyo plan there's still an
airport by futsu but now there's also
another International Airport planned
for the center of the Bay
the neotokyo plan is detailed but like
kana's Plan before it the Neo Tokyo plan
didn't come without its critics critics
who also had ideas for what needed to
happen to the Bay
in the 1960s a group of Japanese
Architects introduced a new
architectural philosophy
we hope to create something which even
in destruction will cause subsequent New
Creation
this something must be found in the form
of the Cities we were going to make
cities constantly undergoing the process
of metabolism
I didn't I didn't really understand any
of that either for these five kind of
pretentious Architects cities were not
concrete rigid and flexible structures
they were organisms
of a larger constantly changing system
that could easily be changed and
destroyed while the form remained the
same roads were like nerves and a much
larger nervous system different
functions of the city acted like organs
these metabolists conjured up radically
new ideas for architecture dreaming up
ideas for cities that look like giant
animals buildings that were as much part
of the sky as the land
an architecture designed to grow
Contracting and expanding with time
the metabolists were ambitious and they
had ideas for what needed to happen to
the Bay
first of the metabolists to go against
the Neo Tokyo plan is otaka instead of
moving tons of soil and still requiring
foundations
otaka believed that the bay should be
filled with high-rise Apartments built
on pillars directly above water
instead of moving tons of soil they only
need to build a bunch of small mini
Islands
according to otaka but probably not to
any structural engineer the pillars with
some occasional use of land would be
much less expensive than filling the
entire Bay
[Music]
for zoning otaka designed it so that the
industrial areas face the opening side
of the Bay
the residential housing would be placed
on an outer belt which was then sliced
by commercial zones
for transportation there would be an
interlude Highway and Railway
like kano's Plan before it otaka's
industrial belt is also purposely dug 20
meters deep for docking
otaka was one of the few metabolists to
actually be taken seriously the plants
that came after him were a much harder
pill to swallow
kurokawa was a young 25 year old
architect who presented two separate
plans for the bay
first first he suggested converting the
city into a giant organism that reached
into the bay
the city would be built with two
metaphorical hands one for International
Communication and the other for domestic
it would have a head serving as the
central axis an entrance to the capital
Crossing his City diagonally are two
other separate axes dotted with two
buildings he had designed the buildings
were intended to hold entire Villages
the bamboo housing community and the
plant housing community
for a second planned kurokaw would be
even more ambitious
called The Ocean City he proposes
building Helix land units that could be
connected on top by a giant Highway
these helixes would connect to form much
larger cells which were then connected
by more highways forming a nervous
system that could expand organically
like a slime mold
parts of the cell could then be taken
away and then the form would still
remain slowly retracting and Contracting
into the Tokyo bay
both of kurokawa's plans were considered
unrealistic but even he was not the most
radical of the metabolists
was obsessed with building
megastructures and leaving the ground
he dreamed up ideas of tightly packing
floating hexagons to build cities on top
of expandable chains of floating balls
and drifting cylinder cities with
buildings that served as buoys
kikutake's plan for the Tokyo bay was
one of the most ambitious but also one
of the most obscure
it was the most visually limited of all
the plans that were presented but also
the largest
he created three separate boroughs
a Borough by Kyoto to protect against
flooding another by harumi and the most
staggering a grid that stretched across
the entire Bay
all three boroughs were connected by a
gigantic Loop Highway and the biggest
Grid in the middle of the bay would
contain floating housing and factories
that linked together with the grid Road
system
when certain elements of the city became
redundant they could be released off of
the megastructure and be sunk
all of these plans made by the
metabolists had some common features
they were large they were designed to
maintain an overall shape even if
certain pieces were removed and they
were all connected by extensive roadways
if you looked far enough you could also
catch a glimpse of something alive
but another thing that binded the
metabolists was their teacher and leader
Kenzo tange
the man who designed the most extensive
plan for the Tokyo bay and it came
pretty damn close to actually being
successful
tange was the blend between all four
plans for the bay
he had the political will and savviness
of Kano he made his plan public and
mobilized media to get his ideas into
the minds of citizens and actual
politicians
like kurokawa he imagined a structure
that was built on a giant spine which
also grew overtime from the mainland
City
like hekutake he fetishized the idea of
a massive megastructure
and like otaka he also wanted to build
on pillars
this is Kenzo tange's plan for the Tokyo
bay
a linear City that builds off of a
massive looping spine
his City would house 10 million people
and like kano's Plan before it connect
to Tokyo City with Chiba on the other
side of the Bay
each vertebrae is a nine kilometer long
unit which consists of three decks of
looping highways
perpendicular to the major spine roads
would connect to A-frame megastructures
a 138 meter tall Mega structure that had
its own artificial ground
within the spine are zones for
government buildings offices shopping
hotels Recreation a new Central Station
and a new Harbor
the buildings within the spine are also
constructed on pillars so that they can
hover above the ground
like kurokawa tange believed in creating
a system that could procedurally grow
over time
as opposed to radial growth tange
advocated for linear growth inspired by
the development of the spines in mammals
he also believed that the future of
cities revolved around the car so his
plan was made highly dependent on the
use of the automobile
it was also an attempt to control it
Kenzo was responding to a world that was
undergoing rapid development
an idea to control and organize a
society that was growing rapidly
but for all the effort that was put in
kenzo's plan and the others none
actually became a reality
they were too large too intimidating and
too much of a risk
but Tokyo still expanded into the bay
over the years the city has climbed into
the bay slowly from all sides but just
with no utopian grand plan in sight
there may not be a linear City built on
water but today more than 15 percent of
the Tokyo bay has been reclaimed and
even in 2022 there are still dreams to
build on the bay
[Music]